facts do not cease to exist
because they are ignored
words can be like x-rays if you use them
properly
they'll go through anything
you read and you're pierced
after silence
that which comes nearest to expressing
the inexpressible
is music
but i don't want comfort
i want god
i want poetry
i want real danger
i want freedom
i want goodness
i want sin
you shall know the truth
and the truth shall make you mad
maybe this world is another planet's
hell
i wanted to change the world
but i have found that the only thing one
can be sure of changing is oneself
it is terrible when a person knows how
to say the wrong things correctly
one believes things because one has been
conditioned to believe them
there are things known
and there are things unknown
and in between are the doors of
perception
history is like meat pate
it's better not to peer at how it is
prepared
you can forgive a person
everything
except absence
words are good servants
but bad masters
the secret of genius is to carry the
spirit of the child into old age
which means never losing your enthusiasm
experience is not what happens to a man
it is what a man does
with what happens to him
most human beings have an almost
infinite capacity for taking things for
granted
to appreciate a pie you need to taste it
not look at the recipe
every man's memory
is his private literature
intellectual is a person who has
discovered something more interesting
than sex
consistency is contrary to nature
contrary to life
the only completely consistent people
are the dead
there is only one corner of the universe
you can be certain of improving
and that's your own self
you can smile
smile more
and still be a bastard
no social stability without individual
stability
i'd rather be myself
myself and nasty not somebody else
however jolly
to travel is to discover that everyone
is wrong about other countries
[Music]
the propaganda's purpose is to make one
set of people forget that certain other
sets of people are human
experience teaches only the teachable
great is truth
but still greater
from a practical point of view
is silence about truth
i'm afraid of losing my obscurity
genuineness only thrives in the dark
like celery
ending is better than mending
it is natural to believe in god when
you're alone
quite alone in the night
thinking about death
it isn't a matter of forgetting
what one has to learn is how to remember
and yet be free of the past
we are all geniuses
up to the age of ten
all gods are homemade and it is we who
pull their strings
and so
give them the power to pull ours
never put off till tomorrow
the fun you can have today
the fact that people do not learn from
the mistakes of history
is the most important lesson of history
if most of us remain in the dark about
ourselves
it is because self-knowledge is painful
and we prefer pleasant illusions to it
the end cannot justify the means
for the simple and obvious reason
that the means determine the nature of
the end
if your wife cheated on you
do not ask how many times she did it
because it can really amaze you
it is not good to become an adult
if you haven't read all the children's
books
seeing yourself as others see us is the
most salutory gift
in bed with your mistress do not forget
that your place next to your wife is now
vacant
the facts of history interest us
not only if they fit into our political
convictions
how wonderful
interesting
original people are
from a distance
being together does not mean to love
each other
or to trust each other
you